it roamed the earth a hundred million
years ago now it's back from the depths
it remains revealed for the first time
paleontologists have called it maraxis
gigas after a fictional dragon from the
game of thrones television series
they say it's the biggest find of its
kind yet
maraxis is important because it is the
first time we have the very complete
fossil of the kakaridontosaur a special
group of dinosaurs it is so complete
that we know everything from the whole
arm down to the smallest toes the whole
foot and the length of the head we have
a lot of information and this has never
happened
before though unrelated to the
tyrannosaurus rex it's similar in build
and features discovered in northern
patagonia in 2012 it's taken a decade to
excavate the find spreads light on how
these huge predators evolved
they are the largest carnivorous
dinosaurs that ever existed but until
now we didn't have a complete skull for
example so many measurements were given
that in reality we're not certain and
finally we can establish the true size
of the skull the arms the legs and this
is fundamental to understand the
evolution of this lineage
the fossilized remains are remarkably
well preserved providing more pieces to
the prehistoric puzzle
cara leg al jazeera